bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale grand champion de l'histoire du
jeu d'échecs avec jérôme on fera ça lui
jérôme salle et stéphane alors
aujourd'hui on va voir un joueur caf
marquer son empreinte août la fin du
xxème siècle puisque c'est le très grand
anatoli karpov à l'atelier est bien
évident karpov né en 1951 that oust en
oural et qui a été champion du monde en
1975 jusqu'en 1985 et il a perdu son
titre contre garry kasparov mal et en
plus ce malgré qu'il ait perdu au moins
revenir sur son parcours bien sûr mais
malgré qu'il ait perdu 1,85
il a continué à jouer des matches de
championnat du monde il est revenu
plusieurs fois
re disputer le titre à kasparov et ça
jusqu'en 1993 je crois que la dernière
confrontation qui a eu oui je crois que
c'est ça et il a re obtenu un titre de
champion du monde mais c'est ainsi tout
championnat qui est pas le titre chaque
classique parce qu'il n'a pas battu
kasparov il avait joué le titre fidh
lors de la scission la grande scission
on verra ça notamment dans là dans
l'émission aussi avec k sport mais même
là il faudra commencer à en parler
il a retenu le titre de championne du
monde en 98 je crois donc bien plus tard
il là il a gardé encore quelques années
donc il ya une longévité aussi qui est
assez étonnante tu soulignait le fait
qu'il ya eu des matchs trois manches
contre kasparov celui 87 a sévi
notamment où les deux adversaires
termine 12 partout et kasparov de garde
le titre que parce que la règle prévoit
que le champion en titre conserve le
titre en cas de match nul mais on peut
dire qu'en 87 karpov et au niveau de
quatre sports offrira quand l'écart
souci là dessus très clair et donc ce
sont deux joueurs qui se sont affrontés
en tout dans 144 partie de championnat
du monde et karpov n'a un résultat sur
144 parti que de -2 c'est à dire que
l'afrique deux parties en tout cas
kasparov de plus qu'ils n'en aient gagné
lui-même la différence entre les deux
joueurs dans les années 80 elle est un
film en réalité né un fils exactement
donc in et en oural et l'oral c'est pas
spécialement un endroit de la russie
très propice au développement et fikin
pas particulièrement mais mais pas moins
que d'autres régions on a du temps pour
jouer aux échecs en ouvrant le petit
selon la légende le petit anatoli karpov
aurait appris en regardant son père
jouer avec le voisin il ya beaucoup de
légendes de cet ordre là qui courent sur
le sur les grands joueurs d'échecs en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il a
appris vers quatre ans ce qui est très
très jeune parce que c'est rare qu'un
enfant puisse comprendre accepter des
règles immuables comme celle du jeu
d'échecs à un âge aussi précoce toujours
est il que son père qui était ingénieur
lui a montré le mouvement des pièces et
que à que l'enfance en étiez s'est
passionné pour le jeu d'ailleurs
apparemment au grand grand désarroi de
sa mère qui lui a un moment supprimer
les chics et parce qu'elle était un
petit peu inquiète
et puis un jour elle est rentrée dans la
chambre d'anatolie et puis regardez le
plafond est en fait il était en train de
jouer l'aveuglent de rejoindre avec des
partis qui le mur dans un recueil de
parties de capablanca qui était son
livre de chevet à la boxe avait il
imaginé des 6 pieds 1 sat est gêné
l'échiquier donc ça m'avait privé
d'échiquier physique mais lui il avait
l'échiquier virtuel en tête donc se
montrer aussi ses prédispositions
évidente pour le jeu d'échecs ses
prédispositions
il met en valeur assez rapidement
puisque à l'âge de 16 de 9 10 ans il est
déjà dans le championnat junior du rss
donc on est d'aller déjà dans les années
60 la démo en hausse entre 71 et il fait
5 sur 10 au championnat junior alors que
il ya du tout dans sa catégorie et
juniors luis et ont 18 ans entre 18 et
20 ans donc il a déjà avec montre des
signes de précocité de compréhension du
jeu qui sont évidents il rentre à
l'école boulle vinik nom de l'ancien
champion du monde à 12 ans et là aussi
étonnant que ça puisse paraître on a le
témoignage de bobigny en tout cas un
jugement très sévère de bobigny qui sur
karpov qui lie ce garçon ne comprend
rien aux échecs il ne fera jamais
carrière dans cette profession
après alors comme quoi un maudit
commence à se faire vieux
c'est ce à quoi ils avaient peut-être
pas tout compris de la profondeur du
style de karpov qui aurait pu passer
entre guillemets inaperçue ou qui
auraient pu se retrouver sur une voie de
garage si il n'avait pas montré des
justement à bobigny qui par la suite
qu'il s'était lourdement trompés sur son
cas une devient champion du monde
juniors par la suite donc ça c'est en
1900 1969 il a 18 ans d'accord champion
du monde junior il obtient son titre de
maître international la même année puis
au tournoi de caracas en 69 70 il
devient grand maître international
voilà donc là ça y est il est au top du
top il a quoi il a 18 18 19 18 19 voilà
il est il arrive à ce niveau là en
pleine domination mondiale de spa skis
fischer faire qu'il est entre les deux
c'est fischer qui va devenir champion du
monde donc ils arrivent ils arrivent à
maturité finalement au moment où fischer
lui-même est au top de sa carrière en 72
il obtient le titre de champion du monde
et karpov et fait partie flamande et des
jeunes grands maîtres qui monte à ce
moment là qu'on voit là il fait partie
des jeunes grands maîtres qui monte mais
en urss il suffit pas de monter il faut
aussi s'affirmer
parce que on a une armada de champion du
monde ancien champion du monde
m et très fort joueur devant lesquels il
est nécessaire de s'imposer aussi pour
montrer qu'on peut devenir le leader des
joueurs de l'union soviétique et c'est
ce que fait talent en 1971 au mémorial
ali king oui fini premier avec stein
devant smith loft al petrossian espace
qui karpov karpov menait tu as du talent
devant talent tellement fait la
cartophilie premier ex-aequo avec stein
de vandales qui s'affirme à ce moment-là
il s'affirme à ce moment-là nous
seulement aux yeux des autres joueurs
d'union soviétique mais aussi aux yeux
du monde
on comprend que les élus et 16 tient là
un jeune jeune prodige et qu'il a
sûrement beaucoup de beaucoup de venir
et là il est dans le cycle déjà puisque
du centre du championnat du monde pour
75 c'est à dire qu'il va rentrer dans ce
cycle et à avoir des résultats avec ces
passionnés
oui il va peu le gars qui en quarts de
finale et se qualifie pas ensuite pour
la finale où il va rencontrer viktor
cochonneries et on ne sait pas encore à
ce moment là mais cette finale des
candidats et sera en fait la finale du
championnat du monde puisque bobby
fischer ne défendra pas son titre en 75
il sera destitué de son titre par la
fille d et de fait le vainqueur de la
finale des candidats karpov et bien que
devient champion du monde sur le tapis
vert ce qui a toujours été je crois un
souci pour karpov puisque quand on
devient champion du monde sur tapis vert
on a un petit peu moins de légitimité
que si on a emporté en dans un véritable
match ce titre encore plus s'ils avaient
pu emporter devant bobby fischer est en
tout cas le match le match car paul
fischer en 75 aurait été assez
extraordinaire je crois oui ben oui
c'est sûr que d'un point de vue
strictement et chicken au profit du jour
on a beaucoup perdu à pas voir fiche a
rejoué depuis l'allée d'un point de vue
par contre de la légende
on a gagné autre chose mais alors ce
soit 75 c'est quand même donc très
particulier pour la carrière de karpov
puisqu'il devient champion du monde un
peu sur tapis vert
donc quand tu viens de le dire puisque
par défaut de fischer
fischer est d'ailleurs n'a plus donné
signe de vie depuis 30 12
ici c'est vraiment isolé du monde dont
on a pas on parle de ça dans on parle de
ça dans l'émission sur sur bobby fischer
particulièrement mais on peut citer deux
choses à propos de ce championnat du
monde 75 c'est que c'est ce manque de
combat pour devenir champion du monde
pour ce titre de champion du monde de
karpov va faire qu'il va en fait de voir
enfin il va vouloir justifier son titre
et de jouer énormément de tournois donc
ça va être une des clefs de sa de
compréhension de sa carrière il va jouer
beaucoup beaucoup de tournants ils vont
gagner énormément il a le record mondial
du titre détonnant on va revenir dessus
en tout et pour tout il ya eu 160 places
de premier soit dans des tournois
individuels les compétitions par équipes
ou des matches contre des joueurs 160
places de premier essai que tout à fait
exceptionnelle et il ya un autre point
aussi puisqu'ils jouent des bijoux des
75 ce match que face à cornol et qui va
bien sûr être son sparring partner leur
vie d'hier pendant longtemps parce que
jusqu'à 80 donc ça fait presque six ans
d'affilée ou corn oil à lui il va lui
tenter lui ravir sa couronne et déjà
corps je n'en avais dit à ce moment là
s'il ya aussi ce qui va marquer la
carrière de karpov que finalement le
régime préférait plus avantagés car
pauvre que lui corse noël qui était un
peu beaucoup plus individualiste alors
que karpov était à l'aise finalement
dans le système soviétique enfin tout
casser l'image qu'on avait lu à cette
époque et qui l'a jamais vraiment
démenti et qui avait aussi d'ailleurs
été critiqué la même façon par kasparov
kasparov se présenter un peu comme elles
ont un programme chef en propre et
restent rares cas dans l'est dans les
années 80 et 4 fois plus tôt comme le
chouchou du édition du régime soviétique
il est évident qu'au début des années 70
quand l'urss vie le traumatisme de la
perte du titre contre bobby fischer
karpov est encouragé soutenu parce que
c'est visiblement le plus jeune et plus
talentueux à ce moment là et qui devient
l'enfant chéri du régime de la
fédération des échecs soviétique et
c'est lui visiblement ce n'est post pas
de problème on a souvent dit que c'était
un peu un apparatchik oui là il a
participé il a participé au régime il a
eu un rôle un rôle actif
l'uci fait leurs députés il a été député
à la douma et douma donc il a d'une
certaine façon participé à ce régime et
puis c'est un c'est un russe pur sucre
donc c'est pour ça aussi il était aussi
soutenu des joueurs comme petrossian
talent qui venait des marges de l'union
soviétique ou même kasparov était moins
favorisés par le pouvoir central plus
russophiles une nouvelle fois oublié que
l'urss c'est l'agrégat de 22 22 et à 22
fédérations et que dont certaines ont
des fortes
revendications nationales les estoniens
et lettons etc se considère comme russe
20 comme soviétique en deuxième et
d'abord comme de leur nationalité ne
sont pas des russes à proprement parler
connaissent pas décelables quoi sont pas
forcément des slaves non plus voilà
aussi bien les géorgiens que les
arméniens sont quand même un petit peu
différent des rues c'est en tout cas le
pouvoir soviétique même s'il était un
communiste avait quand même une
préférence pour les véritables entre
guillemets russe et karpov et et était à
la fois donc un enfant chéri du régime
un russe pur sucre et pas dire qu'il se
complaisait dans ce rôle mais en tout
cas elle n'a rien fait pour le pour le
démentir alors il a dû affirme
effectivement cette illégitimité temps
des tournois il en a disputé une
trentaine de très très grands tournois
entre 75 et 85
il en a gagné 23 sur 38 énormément et
c'est énorme alors je tique burg
hambourg skopje tous les tous les grands
tournois de l'époque les a il les a
gagnées jeu quand il n'a pas gagné il a
fini 2e ou 3e de toute façon donc il a
fait une véritable razzia surtout tous
les grands tournois de l'époque et a
voulu compenser le manque de légitimité
de son titre de champion du monde par ce
surcroît d'activité dans les tournois
wpt est tout à fait donc de ce côté-là
il a été un champion de monde qui joue
et je crois qu'il a vraiment beaucoup
fait pour les échecs il a écrit aussi
bien il ya des livres de karpov qui sont
tout à fait intéressant et qui servait
non ils sont très très bien vient savez
c'est un des champions du monde qui a
écrit lemieux qui a le mieux expliquer
son jeu donc
alors on arrive ensuite à 78,80 ça c'est
les deux matches face à accords je n'en
ai que l'on est toujours au top et qui a
manqué finalement ce titre de champion
du monde presque on va dire trois fois 1
3 fois il s'est fait finalement barrer
la route par par karpov qui a chaque
fois quand même et surtout en 78 81 à
montrer des signes de faiblesse déjà de
faiblesse physique de
difficulté à finir le match même en 75
le match est terminé je crois sur un
score de 3 2 avec leur match a été assez
long et karpov avait était apparu
amaigri et la fin du match de la même
façon en 78 alors qu'il menait assez
largement s'est fait rejoindre par
corchia il ya qu à merano en 80 qui là
qu'il a réussi à faire à écourter un
petit peu le match parce que encore tu
as été un tout petit peu vieillissant
mais c'est vrai que c'est un joueur qui
avait du mal quelquefois à terminer ses
matches et on verra que contre kasparov
ça a eu un rôle très important
oui donc après arrive kasparov c'est à
dire que après la parenthèse
enfin après la parenthèse pas une
parenthèse après les grands matches face
à corps chinois et c'était des grands
matches tout à fait tout à fait sportif
tout à fait tendues avec une un arrière
plan politique puisque il ya encore je
n'y étais pas et est parti en 80 des
suisses et déjà ils étaient ils étaient
dissidents donc avec encore des re des
relents de guerre froide
à la suite du match c'est parce qu'ils
fischer ce n'était pas fini et aussi des
dissidences russe qui partent et au
moment où kasparov arrive en finale du
championnat du monde c'est 84 le premier
grand match
alors sans doute un sommet au sila de la
médiatisation du jeu d'échec parce que
kaspar se présente comme disons le fer
de lance de la delà de la nouvelle vague
russe qui est plutôt donc en faveur de
la fameuse pérestroïka de gorbatchev on
sent déjà finalement enfin avec le recul
on voit que c'est une période où
l'empiré soviétique commence à se
fissurer
puisque ce n'est que quelques années
plus tard en 87 je crois que le mot 89
ans que le mur de berlin se brise et
c'est un peu le c'est un peu le symbole
kasparov comme ça de cette au niveau et
chiquet mais sur deux sets de 7 pouces
et politiques internes à l' empire
soviétique
oui c'est certain le match entre karpov
et kasparov donner le sentiment qu'on
est on met face à face l'ancienne
génération celle de brejnev celle du
total nie pas la dictature du secret
aussi du secret de l'appareil d'état
surpuissant et puis kasparov se présente
comme lui l'enfant du changement c'est
le titre de son autobiographie
celui qui incarne les nouvelles valeurs
de transparence on en reparlera mais il
n'hésite pas à aller donner des
interviews dans des journaux occidentaux
chose qui se faisait assez peu a
critiqué le régime ou à encourager
certaines mesures a déjà parlé de
démocratie
à une époque où en urss on n'était plus
habitué à suivre la ligne politique
surtout que l'urss c'était très
fortement réduit sur ses positions dans
les années 70 c'est notamment après 79
et
pianiste ans donc quand karpov et
kasparov s'affrontent c'est vraiment en
tout cas on a le sentiment vu de
l'extérieur que c'est l'ancien ancienne
urss contre celle qui se se préfigure
qui va arriver dans les années qui vont
suivre et on sent la tension politique
puisque ce match est tout à fait
extraordinaire il a fini par attirer et
finit par attirer l'attention parce
qu'au départ pas trop et finit par
attirer l'attention des médias du monde
entier il a lu à moscou où il est en
plein un bon c'est normal c'est de
russie à la limite c'était facile là
également ce coup mais pourquoi il
attire toute l'attention des médias du
monde entier parce que ce match dure six
mois
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire on a un
style de match qui finalement a hérité
de la règle fischer finalement c'est
fisher qui avait remis au goût du jour
un type de match sans fin finalement
puisque c'est le premier à six qui gagne
la partie est alors un peu comme face à
korphe non je crois en 78 carpeaux dans
ce match arrive à gala a mené assez vite
fait assez vite au bout de fait en 30
parties je sais oui et il finit par
mener 5 1 je crois 5/0 5/0 5/0 5/0 5/0
mai mais il bloque les blocs à ce moment
là de façon assez inexplicable 5 0 c'est
quand même la raclée pour casser un clip
il faut rappeler que kasparov est très
très jeune et très 23 ans il a 23 ans il
a n'a pas encore de légitimité très très
forte est même veine 2 puisqu'il
obtiendrait 23 ans et l'année d'après à
voir la peine légitime est
extraordinairement fort qu'il ya
beaucoup de grands maîtres sur youtube
qui disent qu ils arrivés là un petit
peu par l'effet des circonstances que la
battue cornouaille en finale les
candidats mais bon ça c'est fait parce
que quand je dois y était vieillissant
valve on trouve beaucoup d'explications
et tous les gens qui doutaient de
kasparov dise voilà c'est un gamin il
est en train de se faire laminer 1 02 03
04 05 0 il va prendre six essais
et sa carrière sera terminée voilà ces
moments là c'est ce qu'a dit karpov
après si j'avais pu finir ce match parce
qu'en fait tu étais fou tu t'es foutu
mais alors ce qui s'est passé 5 0
peut-être que karpov s'est un petit peu
aurait dit apparemment il a il a été un
moins chercher une initiative elle a
attendu peut-être un peu l'erreur de des
puits et puis kasparov a appris s'est
rendu compte qu'il pouvait pas gagner
aussi facilement finalement qu'il avait
écrasé d'autres candidats parce qu'il
faut pas oublier quand même que son
parcours est fulgurant il a écrasé c'est
vrai les autres candidats pour arriver
en finale
à noter que je crois que c'est là qui
bat smith l'offre l'ancien champion du
monde qui a plus de 60 ans à ce
moment-là bon mais ça on le verra dans
l'émission consacrée à kasparov en
particulier mais il a écrasé tous ses
joueurs et donc il pense qu'une contre
karpov qui va pouvoir faire pareil mais
non c'est karpov s'est quand même il est
la part il est là quand même depuis
maintenant neuf ans au top du top
mondial il a gagné beaucoup de tournois
et l'expérience en plus du très grand
talent et caspar on se rend compte que
ta petite finale enlevée le jeu de la
prof est beaucoup plus profond que tout
ce qui pouvait penser et qui n'arrive
pas du tout à passer ces attaques qui
sont au contraire bien démonté par par
karpov dans la profondeur et lutter mais
au bout de 5 0 finalement kasparov se
dit mais je vais essayer de faire des
nuls pour faire durer le match justement
ça c'est c'est la stratégie qu'ils
adoptent s'est dit bon je prends moins
de risques jeu
je cherche des position équilibrée et
puis si ça fait nul et par moment on
continue le match je suis encore vivant
et puis s'il ya un moment karpov fait
une erreur j'en profiterai et puis
l'espace in stratégie qui commence à
fonctionner alors déjà alors je crois
qu'il ya quelque chose qu'on me faire
enfin partie dure qui suivent donc comme
ça m'avait il y en a une bonne série
une bonne quinzaine et puis et puis à la
5e un 5-1 quelques nuls encore 5 de
quelques nuls encore 5 3 5 3 et là et là
alors là c'est le je dirais le coup de
théâtre
impensable des années 80 parce que c'est
alors je pense que le jeu d'échecs après
a vécu des années sur ce sur sur cet
événement tout à fait tout à fait
improbable
le président à ce moment-là de la
fédération internationale des échecs
étaient campo madness florencio joueront
à ces formations semaine un philippin
sans doute on suppose téléguidé par les
instances russe en france mais ses
complices et passivité pas si claire
décide d'arrêter le match parce que ça
fait quand même six mois que ça dure
mais on voit kasparov qui remonte et
tout le monde se dit mais l'art est le
match parce que kasparov et karpov est
foutu il est physiquement complètement
cuit kasparov est en train de revenir et
il va le manger tout cru et
c'est sans doute la raison pour laquelle
il arrête le match en tout cas kasparov
fait une sortie théâtrale pour dénoncer
cet arrêt du match qui sera reconduit en
85 l'année plus tard mais cette fois en
partie limité
oui et on recommence à 00 heures c'est
un petit peu c'est quand même assez
incroyable parce que l'interprétation de
cet événement qui est vrai qu'il est
secoué le montrent et chicken est
difficile parce que certains ont dit ah
bah voilà
car profs étaient étaient cuits la
fédération soviétique s'en aperçoit elle
fait pression sur caen romanesque campe
omnes arrête le match
ça c'est le scénario numéro un karpov
des années après digues mais tandis que
je menais quand même 5 3 j'avais quand
même encore deux points d'avance dont kg
plus qu'une partie à gagner mais aussi
j'ai pas spécialement a intérêt à
arrêter match pourquoi commencer à 0 0
si on réfléchit rationnellement karpov
avait pas spécialement
c'est le scénario ou tel qu'il s'est
déroulé dans la réalité n'a pas avantagé
car pop donc lui il s'en est défendu il
a dit qu'au contraire c'était pas ça
venait pas du tout de lui en tout cas et
que lui n'était pas du tout d'accord
pour commencer à 0 0 et sur était
fatigué bien sûr il voulait une
interruption il voulait reprendre un peu
son souffle mais et recommencer à 5-3
c'était ça qui ne voulaient pas 0-0 et
d'une certaine façon
toutes ces parties qui ont été joués
jusqu'à 5 3 ont servi d'entraînement à
kasparov puisque il a pu prendre la
mesure de karpov de son style et ensuite
le dépasser et quand qu'il joue le match
revanche je sais pas comment l'appeler
le match qui a suivi et qui a recommencé
à 0 0 bien la casse par off n'est plus
tout à fait le même joueur karpov menait
beaucoup pas pris il a beaucoup appris
karpov n'est plus tout aussi dominateur
qui peut l'être au début du premier
match et kasparov fini par l'emporter
voilà est là car pauvre perd son titre
qu'il ne récupérera pas dans la lignée
des champions classique c'est-à-dire en
revenant mais il revient quand même en
toujours il domine toujours le monde est
sur c'est en fait c'est la domination
des kasparov et karpov des deux cas
pendants mais alors très longtemps
jusqu'en 95 jusqu'à ce que la nand
finissent par arriver en finale du
championnat du monde et en 87 c'est
encore un match kasparov et karpov qui
est cette fois donc utilisé à deux
doigts de basculer en faveur de karpov
puisque c'est à séville et il ya là
aussi un coup de tête mais l'ap sur
l'échiquier pas en dehors c'est mieux
quand même car pour gagner l'avant
dernière mais kaspar revient la dernière
partie est en cas de match nul c'est le
champion qu'il garde le titre en 90 deux
nouveaux matches karpov et kasparov ce
sera le dernier puisque lors s'essuyer
de lyon est là cette fois par contre
kasparov l'emportent clairement oui
maintenant la 190 kasparov vient
d'atteindre le plus haut classement
jamais atteint qui est de 2800 way et
karpov est un petit peu plus un petit
peu plus âgé il a passé son pic de
maturité et de force et ils cèdent un
peu plus facilement devant kasparov
mais je rappelle quand même 1 au total
des 144 partie disputée entre les deux
et que moins deux pour carte offre oui
c'est rien du tout alors la carac harper
n'est pas fini puisque il arrivera plus
en finale du championnat du monde
classique il
kasparov va dominer caen continue à
dominer le jeu d'échec puisque jusque
dans les années 2000 est là karpov donc
va par contre continuer à gagner des
tournois notamment il va gagner un
magnifique tournée linares avec une
performance extraordinaire à trois mille
à trois mille 100 lots de perf un truc
j'ai eu en 94 je crois oui
donc manier un tournant extraordinaire
caspar ne lui même y croyait pas il
jouer ce tournoi là mais il a fait je
suis plus que le score c'est un
hallucinant et c'était quand même à 43
ans il part donc il a quand même
maintenu un très très très haut niveau
assez longtemps dans ensuite l'histoire
des championnats du monde s'est
largement compliqué puisqu'il ya une
scission une scission donc lavé la
fédération nationale joue à jouer à
organiser son propre championnat du
monde à côté du championnat du monde que
la classique est là
karpov revient en jeu par miracle en
quelque sorte
voilà il décide que pourquoi pas jouer
le championnat du monde de la fifa des
puisque c'est quand même la fit et qui
est organisée c'est la fédération qui
régit le monde des échecs
il décide de jouer ces championnats et
puis ils l'emportent donc il redevient
champion du monde et c'est un petit peu
comme en boxe et à partir du moment où
il ya deux championnats du monde
concurrents c'est ça a moins de valeur
forcément bien sûr jouer la carte titre
unifié
voilà mais quand même c'était en 98 tout
comme à un encart pose de nouveaux
champions du monde méfie des on dire
affidés pour la loco en opposition à
classique de façon à pas briser la
chaîne qui nous lie à l'ebita à aller
nice à steinitz a sillonné mais les deux
à steinitz en 1896 donc toute cette
série de champion du monde qui se sont
passés le titre le flambeau de proche en
proche
alors donc la reprise toujours au top et
qui continue en 2012 encore jouer
quelques tournois
alors évidemment il est un peu moins un
fit est maintenant 2012 qu'il a pu
l'être dans les années 80 et 90 voilà
donc car il n'y a pas tout à fait fini
de karpov nous toujours là et toujours
en pleine forme il joue encore des
tournois il
et qui le gagne encore avec brio on va
voir quelques photos de anatoli karpov
donc ici une première alors c'est à
dortmund se tourne à dortmund le fameux
toit d'entre nous quelle tous les ans au
mois de juillet et si karpov alors
plutôt jeunes ici d'un karpov jeunes en
train jaune jaune mais est ce encore
laissés sur les années 90 puisqu'il a le
drapeau russe puis soviétique
ouais mais plus jeune qu'aujourd'hui
disons voici une deuxième photo de
carpeaux officie en train de regarder
une partie dans son tournoi
on a beau être champion du monde et
avoir gagné des dizaines de tournois on
continue à regarder les parties des
autres comme ça parce que la passion la
passion reprend le dessus
mais peut-être qu'ils jouent le tournoi
et qui se font même la ville romaine
aussi mais regarde quand même les partis
je pourrais que c'est un réflexe chez
tous les joueurs même les mêmes les plus
forts fait rien si vous avez car pauvre
qui vient regarder votre parti c'est un
honneur déjà vous êtes un peu dans
l'histoire du vieux déjà voir dans ces
cas là je conseille une chose très
simple si vous prenez votre temps pour
réfléchir et vous ne jouez rien ça sera
forcément pas le bon mais ils risquent
de partir avec une petite news et saas
alors c'est qu'à terme c'est comme vous
avez un grand maître qui regardent votre
parti vous jouez votre cou et là ce
moment là il s'en va oui bon c'était pas
intéressant de rester
voilà donc ça c'est clair bluff voilà
debout à gauche et enfin une troisième
photo ici voilà de karpov avec donc sans
doute son fils puisque c'est
c'est gary karpov à droite à regarder
car pop là ça va ça fait drôle qui avait
confusion parce qu'ils ont dit non c'est
garry kasparov au nord d'un axe gary
c'est peut-être une forme d'hommage
voilà cette fois ci non c'est pas donc
voilà un karpov
ici encore une fois voilà donc on va
maintenant passer à notre parti du jour
donc entre karpov et donc qui bien
évidemment kasparov salaires c'était
difficile de ne pas choisir une partie
karpov kasparov pour illustrer la
carrière de karpov puisque je pense que
ces deux joueurs ont été la cause de la
grandeur de l'autre voilà deux joueurs
qui ont apporté le jeu d'échecs à des
sommets jusqu'ici inégalée oui c'était
le meilleur ennemi c'est vrai qu'ils
avaient besoin de l'autre les aider à
tenir le haut du pavé
donc les deux cas voici donc cette
partie entre karpov et kasparov
championnat du monde d'échecs avec donc
karpov qui démarre envoyé avec le carton
alors karpov a est connu pour être un
joueur plus tôt jeudi avec un style on
qu'on qualifierait plutôt de
positionnelle - date à dire qu'il va pas
chercher forcément quentin caspar enfer
attentes et l'attaquant permanence à
jouer le sur le fil du rasoir un jeu
plus plus plus difficile à d'ailleurs
même casque kasparov a dit c'est
difficile quand même de qualifier le
signal du style cards off c'est le style
karpov décès de style de karpov là on
peut pas vraiment dire qu'il est
défenseur qui les positionne elle qui
les attaquants il sait tout jouer bien
sûr et la preuve encore dans cette
partie puisqu'il n'hésite pas à jouer le
4 il a ici j'ai toujours eu en fait
karpov et 1 est à un jeu universel avec
un style bien à lui ce qu il s est
positionné le monde compare quelquefois
incapables et encore plus comparé à
comprendre pour le comparer on va le
compare à beaucoup mais c'est vrai qu'il
a été beaucoup influencé par capable en
cas dans sa jeunesse alors que 4 donc
ces cinq alors là par contre c'est lucas
sport pur juste une heure on rentre dans
la sicilienne et on veut chercher les
parties des plus agressif possible du
côté des noirs
donc vous allez voir d'ailleurs comment
dans cette partie est typique des
affrontements carpeaux kasparov parce
que là où caspar officiers de jouer les
parties les plus tendues
caspar carpeaux va choisir les lignes
les plus qu'ils essaient d'éviter le
plus l'initiative pour l'adversaire
il va éviter ce type de malades dont
vous allez voir comment quels livres 3,6
ont entraîné un certain choix kasparov a
aussi joué beaucoup là un âge d'or serre
le cou des six en deux mais là c'est une
autre manoeuvre donc trois des quatre on
ouvre le centre toujours classique de la
sicilienne prise prises et après le coup
qu'avait laissé six on regarde et on
joue qu'avaient les bessac alors secoué
classique ici au regard des joues
contrôler la case des 600 menaçante
c'est un échec puisque je suis protégé
par la dame alors ce sera embêtant
puisque on sera obligé de donner le food
cases noires et ensuite on aurait un
pion arriérés le pion d ici qui n'a plus
de possibilités de jouer un des 600
défenseurs ça sera difficile et c'est
donc il faut jouer des six tout de suite
en juin des six on protège la classe des
six par la dame et par le faux ce qui
empêche cette manoeuvre et la regarder
le coup suivant classique c4 ont peu
joué ces 4000 joue c'est typique ici de
ce que aimé jouer car pauvre cantou
kasparov c'est à dire des des ouvertures
qui limite les possibilités tactiques
contre l'estonienne il jouera beaucoup
la famille notamment il joue en f3
contre l'estonienne bon là on ne s'est
pas du tout le style de cette ouverture
mais il va essayer de limiter
l'expansion noir et les possibilités de
clash tactique des noirs donc ces quatre
c'est difficile pour les pour les noirs
maintenant puisque il faut que les noirs
maintenant pour se libérer joue le coup
des cinq mais voyez qu'il est rendu très
difficile par ses deux pions qui
ressemble à une sorte d'étau de maroci
c'est ça c'est un peu embêtant pour les
normes parce que les joueurs qui ont
joué à sicilienne
et noir veulent jouer souvent des cinq
qu'un coup de libération important qui
est souvent le coup qui permet
d'égaliser de ne plus laisser
l'initiative aux blancs et c4 complique
considérablement la possibilité de cette
manoeuvre
voilà donc on savoir les secoue que les
blancs et c'est devant contenir en
quelque sort contenir la les velléités
noir donc cavalier 6 bon ça ça oblige le
coup suivant un cavalier en c3 alors on
défend le pion ici pas de problème et
sur a6 maintenant par contre on peut pas
revenir ici donc il faut revenir sur la
case à 3 on peut envisager de revenir en
d4 bien sûr mais il ya une autre idée en
venant à trois c'est que on peut se
recycler pourquoi pas plus tard en trois
ans ici et recontrôler une nouvelle fois
regardez c'est qu'on regarde et comment
caspar karpov empêche kasparov à tout
moment de jouer le coup des 5
il faut cette fois aux deux tranquille
petit rock petit rock s'épaississent
voilà donc on est obligé de jouer des
petits coups l'un développement on peut
un peu lent mais bon les noirs n'ont pas
de problème particulier mais on peut pas
dire qu'ils ont pris de l'expansion ils
sont repoussés dans leur propre camp ce
qui convient très bien à karpov qui aime
bien finalement essayé d'améliorer petit
à petit la position de ces pièces
essayer de d'étouffer l'adversaire aussi
c'est un joueur qui est aussi cette
réputation de savoir parfaitement
pousser l'adversaire dans les espaces
réduits et l'étouffé petit à petit
jusqu'à planter aussi des combinaisons
tactiques c'est un très fort tacticien
aussi mais sur karpov mais qui prend son
temps pour préparer ses attaques qui va
jamais essayé de lait trop vite dans les
préparations comme ça qui fait
fructifier un avantage positionnelle
pour à la fin à une fois que l'avantagé
est clair voir justement conclure par
des combinaisons
voilà donc on poursuit développement
normal regarder ces jolies un fou et 3
tranquille on tape un petit peu sur b61
ça c'est une petit pion qui peut être un
peu faible notamment regarder si je vous
fous 17 mai
on pourra plus trop défendre ce pion
deux fois sa fin on sera obligé de jouer
des coups comme qu'avaient les 17
mais on ne pourra pas mettre par exemple
à tour donc ça le foot bien placé il
tape ici ont regardé ce soutien on peut
l'attaquer par dame b 3 on peut
l'attaquer pourquoi pas aussi par
cavalier à quatre et ça peut créer
diffuser encore noir fou bessette quand
même de la part de 2k sports a fait
regarder justement après dun b3 et bien
et attaque double sur v6 tout de suite
déjà mais regarder tranquillement en
développant les pièces un regard toutes
les pièces blanches ont sorti le rock
effet enjoint dame b3 en plus mornes
trouvé une belle place pour l'année
puisque l attaque mais sur mes donc on
le dit peut-être un jouet une tournée 1
le jour où le maître en vis-à-vis de la
dinde et de supions qui qui n'est pas
soutenu par notre pions il est par il
n'est pas faible mais dont il est
pendant on rajoute toujours de la
pression aussi sur la case des scènes
tout simplement
et puis le tour elle sera très bien
passé en c1 en défendant aussi le pion c
ou alors on peut envisager même de
doubler les tours sur la colonne et
c'est bon pour l'instant tant que le
foot c'est yann des six et que c'est que
les tours qui l'attaquent c'est pas
gênant il faudrait une pièce mineurs qui
arrive à trouver le chemin on sait moins
c'est moins clair mais les noirs ont peu
d espace c'est le problème alors la
casse par john cou tendu l'autre coup
ici possible c'est de jouer en été
envisagé gama les 17 alors qu'un tout
petit peu passive puisque le cavalier
attaquera pas le 130 17
ils défendent mais si bien sûr mais bon
c'est aussi une autre possibilité on
peut l'envisager puisque appréhender
cette on peut envisager de venir en c5
ce genre de choses bon il choisit autre
chose kasparov février de plus tendu il
aime jouer les positions de tendue mais
calme alias elle n'empêche pas la prison
v6 puisqu'il ya on attaque la dame donc
la dame peut envisager de prendre b6 et
des carrosses par contre le fait que le
cavalier c6 et bouger à 5 libère le chou
bessette
voilà qui maintenant attaque le pion
4 une deuxième fois donc les noirs ont
peut-être pouvoir se venger voilà l'idée
c'est de se venger sur le pion au 4 mai
vous allez voir que après alors d'un pro
b 6
ici le problème c'est qu'après alors
mais sur kasparov se venge tout de suite
sur le pion leucate qu'elle prend 2,4 et
quasiment forcé on va pas laisser la
prise ici c'est changer et à prix fous
prend le 4 simplement anjou dame prend
des 8es l'énorme problème puisqu'on peut
pas reprendre ici de la tour puisque le
fou et 3 viendrait attaqué à la fois la
tour et le clavier à 5 donc sa force fou
prend des 8es c'est ce qu'a prévu
karpov en fait c'est que il a quand même
pris parce que bay et finalement il a
brisé un peu l'harmonie entre les tours
tout de suite et ils gagnent du temps de
développement tranquillement sans faire
d'efforts il a gardé la paire de fou il
a une structure de pions qui est
toujours parfaite il a ici trois pions
trois pions donc il a deux îlots de
pions et puis bon ben ce cavalier mal
placé donc il peut profiter de ce
mauvais placement c'est s'il vient de
faire d'ailleurs puisque déjà les la
force et c'est ce fou qui n'ont pas très
bien placé ici puisque ce fou ne protège
plus des 6 donc on gagne du temps par
tout simplement tour a des seins voilà
et maintenant il faut défendre le pion
des 6es ont fini son développement avec
un gain de temps ce qui est toujours une
bonne affaire et là que font les noirs
un pas clair que font les noirs ici
alors on peut jouer un coup comme
fou c'est cette ses passifs ainsi qu'on
peut jouer des choses peut-être un peu
plus actives comme houphouët 6 alors on
danse on peut contre-attaqué exactement
là on peut contracter effectivement
parfois aussi le poing de faux et si
c'est que ben on laisse le cavalier à
cinq sens en défense donc le des coups
qu'on me foute v6 sont envisageables
nouvelle cavaliers et puis on empêche
une tour de venir défendre deux pions
des six donc après un coup simple comme
b3 qui est normal on met tous les pions
sur blanc qu'il devienne être accablé
les menaces de sueur sur des six sont là
il faudra bien s'occuper de ça et on ne
peut pas mettre une tour puisqu'il ya
fou décide donc c'est quand même
embêtant
donc pour ces raisons là après tour la
d1 finalement kasparov se lance dans un
truc on peut un peu tendu mais dans son
style quoi il veut pas jouer pas s'ils
voyaient comme il resterait passif dans
cette position donc qui joue un truc
plus plus agressif mais plus tendue
aussi des 5 alors c'est un peu dans les
séries kasparov ne pas jouer de pas
jouer et passifs mais ça ça arrange car
pauvre voyez comme il a poussé un peu
kasparov un peu à la faute
parce qu'après le coup évident f3 belle
évidemment parce que si on prend et or
est fou prend avec un magnifique fou un
défendu par un pion qui n'est plus
attaquable attaque à part un pion qui en
plus comment s'est attaqué à deux et
bien on va on a des problèmes puisque
ben on va perdre un pion quoi comment on
fait alors c'est ce qui d'ailleurs c'est
ce qui va se passer on regarde et après
fou et f5 et de simplement karpov
continue c'est prendre des 5 peut
prendre et 5 et simplement tout
reprendre des sénèque
alors pour l'instant j'ai gagné un pion
et il reste évidemment dans la
possibilité de jouer fouet 6 c'est la
pointe de kasparov puisque je veux me
venger sur le pion à 2 or c'est bien de
se venger sur le pion à 2 mais est ce
qui vaut tout à fait un pion central
c'est pas certain
alors c'est la suite de la découverte
tenant qui va donner raison ou pas aux
joueurs puisque après un tour des six
que font que font les noirs parce que
maintenant c'est le pion à six qui est
menacée il est attaqué deux fois par la
tour en d6 bien sûr qu'il ne s'est posé
sur cette case et puis par le fougueux
d'eux qu'ils étaient
tranquillement développé sur une case
qui avait l'air passive et puis
finalement voilà pas pouvoir attaquer et
prendre ce pion en avant ce qui est
quand même important parce que après
l'option b est un pion passé voilà c'est
à dire qu'après à la prise de ce plan
insiste on se retrouve avec un pion
passé ici le pion b puisque vous prend à
deux alors c'est peut-être le coup cap à
vue caspar enfin dans sa préparation
ici donc le coût des cinq îles et il est
un peu voyez qu'il est un peu léger mais
il est un peu forcé par la précision des
coups de karpov que voiliers qui a petit
à petit pris des petits avantages
devance de développement et qui a poussé
les noirs un peu a essayé de dak de
s'activer pour éviter d'être étouffée et
qui fait une faute avec ce coup de
dessins qui est un peu un peu justes
donc issifou prend à deux bien sûr
mettons pas raciste voilà donc la baie
plein de plus un et puis pas n'importe
quel point parce que si un pion passé
alors ça peut ne pas suffire possible
que kasparov et quand même
volontairement quand même joué cette
ouverture avec l'idée que peut-être
qu'il peut contenir ce pion
maintenant si le jouet en 2012 il ne
faudrait pas je pense que ce parent
enfant à l'époque encore à la limite
pourquoi pas il n'y avait pas les
ordinateurs il n'était pas fort à
l'époque il fallait trouver par soi même
les idées 1 c'était pas clair mais
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est ce pion
est quand même un atout extrêmement fort
mais tourné huit voilà bon alors là
c'est pas facile de maintenant de joux
de fer à d'activer ce pion en amaury
jouer b4 pour attaquer le cavalier
commencé à avancer mais on est déjà sous
pression avec un petit peu intervenir
alors que tous qu internet voilà très
bien très bons coups intermédiaire fous
ces cinq attaques la tour et protège
l'avancé b4 donc après tour hui qu il
faut quand même faire attention au fait
que le fou eux deux ici est attaquée
donc si on tombait 4 évidemment on se
vengerait sur le fou alors si on perd la
paire de fou ça devient plus difficile
donc pour la garder on joue magnifiques
foulées 5 alors c'est superbe
ça c'est la pointe de la pointe de la
pointe de la pointe
ben oui c'est la pointe de carpeaux
viennent puisque là on attaque le fou et
quand on jouera b4 on défendra le fou
c'est 5
donc on consolide à la fois son pion
passé en jouant des quatre puisque il
s'arrache archi protégé par le fou ses
singles et en même temps on l'a avancé
et puis on prépare b4 qui entend
guettant pour le cavalier à 5 parce
qu'on se demande un peu où il peut aller
en plus il lui a expliqué la casse
bessette qui est pas très actives et
très actives alors là kasparov joue le
coup qu'il estime le plus actif dans
cette position tours 6
pour déjà essayé de provoquer un échange
de ces tours qui est quand même
extrêmement active qui est dans le camp
noir et simplement des quatre hommes et
quatre non là où va le cavalier
messieurs alors bon c'est pas évident de
trouver une case pour ce cavalier alors
on peut pas aller en c4 on ne peut pas
aller en c6 qui contrôlé par le fouet
par la tour il reste deux cas soit
bessette soit éventuellement b3 b3 c'est
un petit peu dangereux à cause de fous
ces 4 alors effectivement sur b3 ça fait
un peu peur puisque on se dit par
exemple on pourrait faire pour processes
d'abord pions processes et simplement au
regard des fous ces quatre attaques le
fouet puis crée quand même une petite
pression ici sur ces pièces s'est passé
pas clairement évident ce sillon
pourrait jouer quand même qu'elle est
pensée 5
les princes et saint cloud prend 1,2
faut prendre à lorient on peut reprendre
de la variante cavaler pensée 5 donc ici
maintenant
pion si on fait fou prend à deux la tour
prend l'option b 4 comprend le plan b 4
et c'est fini l'employé qui avait pincé
avec si possible donc peut-être pas
évident donc ici à tourcoing le 6ème
rang le 6 donc plus fort peut-être tout
simplement su jouer simplement fou et 3
on laisse la position dans ces zones là
notamment emmené à ce tournoi dont elle
doit attaque le fou et s'ils le
pouvaient le foot pas de case en fait
tout simplement non
lecavalier pourrait le défendre en c1
mais le retrait du fou en 3 permet de
contrôler cette case
voilà donc voilà tout simplement peut
suffire pour continuer la pression
donc il faut calculer intentions il ya
beaucoup de possibilités même donc on
peut pas tout regardé dans les détails
mais il ya encore du jeu dynamique il
faut regarder mais à chaque fois
l'avantagé des blancs donc tout aussi b4
et l'a donc finalement qu'est-ce qu'on
se résout à jouer qu'à elle et bessède
pour pas permettre de pour pas jouer
qu'à l'e3 il s'enfermer le fou on l'a vu
avec une position pas clair donc ici qui
arrive et c'est très bien et ça attaque
le fou ces cinq les noirs 60 content
d'échanger un fou les fous sont forts et
ils sont non regardez sont extrêmement
actifs comparé au fond noir
et puis ils protègent l'avancée du pion
donc laisse pas faire un cas profondeur
des fous et 2 non il n'ya pas de ya pas
de hasard ce fou et fort il faut le
garder
ils contrôlent la case b6 donc une case
d'avancé du pion il est beaucoup plus
actif que son homologue de quatre mois
fawcett ça c'est logique de la part de
kasparov
je pose la question montrait bien tu es
revenu en f2 mais moi j'attaque
le pion b4 et pas facile de le défendre
n'est pas de coups simples le seul coup
un retard pour je trouve évidemment ces
cavaliers de double avantage de ce coup
je défends mes 4 et 2 ans regarde
attention j'attaque le x 2 donc je gagne
du temps notamment un coup comme four b3
ici serait sans doute
pas forcément un problème pour les
blancs alors il faut trouver une
solution alors si je peux jouer cavalier
bk tout simplement puisque j'attaque à
la fois la tour et le fou et j'oublie
georges oblige les change ici et ça
m'arrange parce qu'après fou prend 1,6
j'ai toujours la prise du fou et après
le par exemple un coucou me fous des
cinq simplement je pousse des scènes je
suis protégé par le fou par le cavalier
j'ai plus qu'à activer matour pourquoi
pas en bo1 d'ailleurs vous la jouer
cavalier sait si ce qui forcerait rouge
quasiment les échanges je peux aussi
proposé que la belle et ses 6 puis
surtout je menace aussi fou j'ai trois
rouges 3 qui attaquent la tour est ici
la tour bouge lecavalier
es tu un peu léger quoi donc il est
encore protégé mais c'est chou donc on
peut aussi envisager des coups comme
tour c1 avec pénétration sur le cac ce
c7
ça c'est très fort aussi donc voyez que
les noirs sont déjà en très très grande
difficulté que les c2 food et 5
donc il faut lui trouver une case voyez
kobe 3 c'était c'était chaud donc fou
des 5
je suis bien placé je suis au centre je
contrôle le bcs a peut être utile ça
peut libérer ma tour sans problème avec
le cavalier donc il faut questionner
pour les blancs le mieux ici c'est
évident c'est le questionner les points
2 les points de défense est ici c'est le
fou des scènes donc tourné à ce fou n'a
pas beaucoup bonnecaze alors évidemment
maintenant clatot et en d1 c'est plus
pareil pour le couffo b3 puisqu'il ya
deux pièces donc on peut venir en b3 la
différence
évidemment c'est qu'il ya une sorte de
d'enfilades ici pas évident de trouver
un coup fort donc là il fallait pour
karpov avoir à trouver les coups
suivants très joli regard des tours 17
on laisse les cavaliers ces deux
reprises parce qu'on prépare sur la
prise du cavalier en c2
c'est très tactique et aurait cette
excuse c'est tactique mais au service de
la danse de la stratégie ici à c'est
toujours pareil c'est d'essayer de
garder ça ici on aurait tout prend pour
prendre tôt on a une qualité en plus
donc il faut reprendre et maintenant on
prend le fou et ça y est le fun club
pions les plus attaquées encore une fois
le client n'ait pu attaquer le pion aux
6 reste est en prise et c'est pas
évident ici pour une mare de trouver un
bon coup notamment un coup comme fou
comme cavalier pardon ici cavaliers par
exemple
en dix huit pour protéger attaquez pas
vraiment le pion à l'opposé on attaque
les deux mais non parce que regarder on
joue simplement fou 17 et on peut pas
prendre ici à cause de à cause d'eux
ainsi on peut on peut envisager par
nantes parce que il ya une petite pointe
encore on peut faire échec ici là oui on
jouait d'abord fou c5 et aux menaces
tour huit échecs qui prend le cavalier
donc qu'au fait la tour sur un échec
roy f2 on a toujours la menace de faire
échec
il faudrait reculer ici par exemple en
g6 et on a une position meilleure à
cause de la paire de fou et de la
faiblesse du pion au 6 mai sans doute
c'est encore jouable c'est dont vous
ignorez leurs économies ou des quatre
qui sera embêtant c'est vrai il ya aussi
encore
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de choses pour
les blancs regardez foulée quatre fous
des cas puisqu'on attaque aussi le pion
simplement le pion un pion g7
voilà une possibilité c'est chaud
beaucoup de choses à calculer moyenne
dans cette position donc tour d un four
b3 c'est une grande escarmouches
tactique sur cette place se sont partis
dont 17
et voilà je contre attaque ici à la fois
sur le fawcett est aussi bien sûr sur le
cavalier parce que je peux aussi créé
des menaces ici par exemple un coup
comme fou mais 3,6 la tour bouge bien un
problème sur le cavalier donc car kaspar
vous un coup de défense actifs tour des
huit alors c'est bien l'idée de des
noirs ici c'est de dire bon s'il ya des
échanges qui se font à la fin j'ai la
possibilité de faire des échecs ici donc
c'est ce que fait d'ailleurs karpov
regarder ce qui va se passer après tout
reprendre six comprend pas la tour en
dix-sept parce que si on la prend au jeu
très tôt précise si les noirs prennent
ici en 6 on peut faire tout simplement
tout reprendre 7 et après fou prince et
2 c'est l'idée de de kasparov après faut
penser de si les blancs prennent le
cavalier on se dit qu'on a une pièce de
plus mais langanu pointe paf échec et le
four au mexique et alors si le four
vient f1 évidemment c'est faut être fou
d'être des droits et pouf s'est perdu et
c'est pas simple et si on joue l'autre
fou évidemment le père donc voilà c'est
la pointe n de kasparov sur tour des
huit c'est une défense en direct donc
après tour prendre 6 plutôt que de
rentrer assez de garanties choisi de
faire en à bord tout reprend 17 quel
autre variante possible
et là que karpov a le choix parce que
soit je reprends la tour soit j'enlève
latour emprise en fait l'autre
possibilité et c'est ce qu'il choisit
surtout tôt un sas est tricards paulien
je défend parfaitement ma première
rangée plutôt que de rentrer dans ses
variantes là j'ai toujours mon pions mon
pions d'avancis six mentions passé et
surtout j'ai là pour 17 qui est qui est
en prise alors la tour doit rester au
contact du fou le set qui est attaqué
donc c'est explique le coup suivant tous
et 7 mai il ya la poigne finale de la c1
une grande combinaison jaune c'est une
combinaison
c'est une grande combinaison mais qui
est toujours sous cette menace
finalement deux de pures en plus un
depuis on passait faux b6 et abandon de
kasparov puisque là il ya plus de
possibilité de défendre le fou alors
c'est on peut dire ambition pourrait
jouer encore on peut se dire ben oui
mais je peux jouer encore trop français
de tout simplement oui mais regardez
maintenant pour prendre le set est
double menace je menace à la fois tout
reprend cavaliers et je fais qui
m'intéresse chez keynote
donc ça explique que la l'abandon de de
kasparov parce que le seul coup ici
qu'on peut envisager ces cavaliers les
six à la fois j'empêche le mat et
j'enlève le cavalier de la prise mais
simplement bonjour est fou c'est 5 et là
que fait le cavalier si je prends le fou
évidemment ça marche parce qu'il ya mat
le câble est en prise si je le défends
je le prends quand même
et puisque je menace mat donc voilà ça
perd une pièce sur 7 sur cette
combinaison final donc très belles
suites
extrêmement tactique que du début à la
fin mais avec ce gain positionnelle au
départ de karpov donc vous avez vu comme
kasparov a essayé par le coût des cinq
finales de rentrer dans une suite
tactique qui sans doute aurait marché
peut-être face à des joueurs moins
précis que karpov et vous avez vu comme
karpov à la fois manille les arguments
positionner c'est à dire le pion de plus
passé sur le côté dames et tout argument
tactiques de pression sucre successives
sur les pieds adverses qui lui permet de
maintenir ce résultat jusqu'à la
combinaison finale et le gain enfin deux
variantes donc quatre mois a fini par
abandonner
en fait alors cette partie est
symptomatique parce que dans les
missions qu'on va vous pourrez voir sur
un kasparov on analyse une autre partie
sur une ouverture semblables ou kasparov
vous finalement le coup des scènes
encore plus tôt voilà et finalement il
est celle à qui va réussir à
déstabiliser karpov donc 7,7
on voit bien que cette tentative de
sortir de l'étau part on va revenir sur
cette position au départ
si je reviens au tout début voilà cette
position des taux ici voilà ses
positions de des taux ici qui sur le
sur le centre ici si les noirs ne font
rien ils vont finir par être étouffée
petit à petit par l'énorme avantage dès
ce parce que qu'on les combis qu'on lit
blanc dans cette position et on a envie
et tôt ou tard de se libérer par des 5
et bien on verra dans cette émission
miroir de karpov c'est sûr kasparov
comment kasparov a finalement tenté un
magnifique giambi qui aura été
d'ailleurs réfutée par la suite mais
bien plus tard mais qu'il a permis de
remporter une magnifique victoire qui
sans doute à contribuer à son titre de
champion du monde
voilà comment on termine cette émission
spéciale karpov encore beaucoup à dire
sur karpov a mis toutes ses victoires en
tournoi il en a fait beaucoup des
parties magnifique mais cette victoire
notamment sur sur kasparov qui fait
partie de ces deux c'est beau succès
avec cette longue suite tactique dans
cette cette ouverture aux cas sport n'a
pas réussi à se sortir de l'étau de la
pop merci jean pour cette émission là
merci stéphane et moi je vous dis à
bientôt pour une autre émission des
gones à tv sur les grands champions de
l'histoire du jeu d'échecs au revoir au
revoir